Donald Trump's lawsuit against Hillary  Clinton  I know it's so stupid Donald Trump's  lawsuit against Hillary Clinton has been  thrown out by a judge this was a lawsuit  which accused Hillary Clinton and dozens  of other Democrats of working together  to accuse him of colluding with Russia  in the 2016 presidential election a  judge has thrown it out and the thing  was basically laughed out of court one  of the things mentioned is that the  statute of limitations has been exceeded  other things that were mentioned were uh  even more humiliating than that if  anybody thought that this lawsuit was  going anywhere I have a bridge to sell  you